eu quero conversar com vocês sobre um
tema que muito me apraz que é o tema da
economia criativa das atividades
culturais e criativas que são aquelas
atividades baseadas na imaginação na
criatividade e também na capacidade dos
seres humanos de tornar a sua imaginação
ea sua criatividade é em produto ou em
experiências né todas essas atividades
elas formam um setor da economia que a
economia criativa e que é um setor
bastante dinâmico no nosso país e no
mundo
quando eu tinha sete anos de idade é eu
fui a los angeles na disneyland com os
meus pais e lá eu vi uma frase que
naquela época me intrigou muito e é algo
que obviamente depois estudando e
conhecendo melhor a disney conhecendo
melhor o ao disney e tudo mais
eu vi isso sendo repetido em vários
lugares mas já naquela época com sete
anos isso me intrigou muito eu demorei
um certo tempo a entender a importância
dessa frase e porque que para o ao
disney essa frase tinha essa importância
tão grande a ponto de ele ficar
repetindo isso disse ser quase
onipresente é na na disney
acho que todo mundo que já foi seja na
flórida seja na califórnia ou alguém que
já leu algum livro sobrou disney enfim
que já teve algum contato com a disney
deve ter visto o papa essa essa frase
porque de fato é algo bastante
emblemático néel disney disse que enfim
que ele esperava que as pessoas não
perderem de vista uma coisa uma coisa
específica que tudo começou com um
camundongo tudo começou com um mickey na
verdade
não na verdade tudo começou com o coelho
né não sei vocês conhecem a história mas
antes do mickey teve um personagem
chamado osvaldo que foi o primeiro que
ele é criou mas enfim não deu certo teve
também uma disputa em relação ao nome
ele decidiu deixar o uso de lado e criou
o omic enfim e foi o nome que deu origem
ao império da disney que é hoje uma
marca é universal
enfim isso aí é pra gente tem uma idéia
do que é a disney hoje né
é só em receitas no ano fiscal de 2008
a disney teve quase 60 bilhões de
dólares é a 14ª marca mais valiosa do
mundo e teve um crescimento de 2017 para
2018 de 8% bastante significativo para
empresas desse porte é de se destacar o
banho e tudo isso começou com um
camundongo tudo isso começou com uma
criação com o talento de um criador
valdisnei que imaginou esse personagem
começou a desenhar criou o personagem ea
partir daí esse império da disney se
criou portanto é a 14ª maior empresa do
mundo em termos de valor de marca ela é
uma empresa que se construiu baseada em
criação em imaginação em talento e em
capacidade de transformar isso em
produto em serviço e experiência
portanto é uma empresa da economia
criativa e é um emblema do que a
economia criativa é capaz de fazer
não existe nenhuma outra área no mundo
nenhuma outra nenhum outro conjunto de
atividades econômicas em que o conceito
de valor agregado de valor adicionado
tenha tanta importância a gente possa
entender perfeitamente o que que isso
é significa bom vamos lá é hoje a
economia criativa é um dos maiores
setores da economia mundial mas são
dados dos estados unidos né
a economia criativa representa 4 pontos
2 por cento do pib americano a gente
está falando de algo em torno de 764
bilhões de dólares por ano
o crescimento é nas últimas décadas tem
muito a ver com a revolução digital
revolução das novas tecnologias mas
enfim o crescimento é exponencial a
gente observa um crescimento de 40%
entre 98 e 2015 quase 5 milhões de
americanos hoje trabalham em atividades
de economia criativa e isso representa
cerca de 3% do total dos postos de
trabalho na economia americana então a
gente tem aí a dimensão do que a
economia criativa realmente a significa
para os estados unidos ea um estudo
recente da consultoria price waterhouse
coopers chamado media e entretenimento
outlook é um dos melhores mais
interessantes sobre a economia criativa
eles atualizam todos os anos mas a
última edição é eles fazem essa
estimativa é de que nos próximos quatro
anos a taxa de crescimento anual desse
setor no mundo vai ser de 4,4 por cento
ao ano que é muito acima da média da
economia mundial para esse período e é
interessante a gente analisar o que que
eles apontam em termos de crescimento
para os diversos segmentos e aí eu vou
fazer também a pontiac com o brasil com
a nossa realidade
enfim a maior taxa de crescimento aí nas
estimativas da praia se dá justamente no
segmento de realidade virtual e
realidade aumentada é hoje é o segmento
mais promissor que apresenta as maiores
perspectivas
a de expansão é no campo da economia
criativa e enfim realidade virtual tende
a estar cada vez mais presente no nosso
dia a dia em áreas e não apenas no que
diz respeito ao consumo aflição de
conteúdos culturais ou de entretenimento
de diversão também no que diz respeito à
medicina e em outras áreas
mas enfim o tite são as plataformas
over-the-top né ô ô ô enfim um vídeo por
demanda streaming e etc para enfim e por
aí vai videogames e esportes a até as
algumas a forma digamos mais
tradicionais mas século 20 é também de
modo de consumo de conteúdos culturais
como cinema também seguem aí como a
perspectiva de crescimento bastante
interessante isso significa basicamente
o seguinte que seja do ponto de vista do
investimento seja do ponto de vista das
nossas carreiras profissionais
as atividades que compõem o campo da
economia criativa são muito promissoras
para todos nós
já valem muito já significam muita coisa
e certamente cresceram muito nos
próximos anos e essa é uma realidade
também aqui no brasil brasil não está
fora disso cada vez mais as atividades
culturais e criativas têm um peso
econômico geram mais emprego geram mais
renda e se afirmam como um campo
bastante interessante em termos
profissionais
hoje as atividades já representam dois
pontos 64 por cento do pib brasileiro
portanto estão no top ten da nossa
economia um milhão de empregos diretos
formais gerados 239 mil empresas e
instituições uma taxa de crescimento
anual de novo aquele estudo da
pricewaterhousecoopers mas aí falando
apenas de brasil né uma projeção de uma
taxa de crescimento anual para os
próximos quatro anos de 5.2 por cento
portanto acima da média mundial da
previsão
é para o mundo e muito acima da previsão
para a economia brasileira como um todo
e aí dois segmentos interessantes é que
são muito fortes aqui no brasil é a
previsão de um crescimento médio anual
de 14 pontos 7 por cento na indústria de
games a gente já tem no brasil uma
indústria de games razoavelmente bem
consolidado o mercado consumidor muito
forte
os brasileiros estão entre aqueles que
mais consomem games e mais tempo dedicam
aos games ea gente já tem aqui no brasil
quase 500 empresas hoje produzindo games
é regularmente com alguns cases de
sucesso muito interessante como raio x e
outros né
e também a questão dos eventos
presenciais é uma marca aqui no brasil
nós brasileiros
adoramos o ao vivo a gente gosta muito
das experiências digitais remotas mas a
gente curte muito ao vivo então a gente
gosta muito de ir a festivais ver
espetáculos é presenciais e isso é uma
tendência muito forte aqui ea estimativa
de crescimento para os próximos anos é
de 8.3 por cento é ao ano bom
são paulo agora o nosso caso específico
aqui em são paulo são paulo é a
vanguarda da economia criativa é
brasileira
nós temos aí vários números que
demonstram isso claramente é as
atividades culturais e criativas
representam 3.9 por cento do pib do
estado é o maior percentual de
participação entre os pibs dos estados
brasileiros são 330 mil empregos 100 mil
empresas e instituições
isso aí representa 47% do pib criativo
do brasil 40% dos empregos do setor
gerados aqui no brasil e 41% das
empresas desse setor também do brasil
portanto são paulo é o coração o são
paulo é o grande vetor da economia
criativa é brasileira
bom não sei dois estudos de caso e
interessantíssimo para compartilhar é é
com vocês que mostram o acerto de se
investir economia criativa também do
ponto de vista do estado do governo do
ponto de vista de políticas públicas
porque os resultados são muito
interessantes são muito estimulantes em
termos de geração de renda e geração de
empregos e geração de oportunidades de
geração de desenvolvimento então se a
gente quer desenvolver o brasil se a
gente quer fazer com que a economia
brasileira tem um perfil econômico
século 21
apostar e investir na economia criativa
é um caminho é fundamental pra isso
então vamos lá começar com o caso da
flip a festa literária internacional de
paraty acho que vocês é certamente
conhecem ou já ouviram falar nesse
evento o evento literário dedicado à
literatura edição de julho de 2018 teve
um custo de 3 6 milhões de reais 3
milhões e 500 mil reais e teve um
impacto econômico total mensurado pela
fgv de 47 milhões de reais
o efeito multiplicador é um para 13 é
muita coisa é muito alto isso foram
1.349 empregos gerados e 4.7 milhões de
reais de impostos arrecadados então
assim é é um tribunal e não é um triplo
ganho você tem o o ganho em termos de
qualificação do repertório é intelectual
da sensibilidade é da formação da
capacitação dos indivíduos que tiveram
acesso esse evento que certamente
participaram de uma experiência
transformadora que as fez melhor ou
melhores em muitos sentidos
a gente tem também o benefício é do
impacto econômico quanto gera de renda
quanto gera emprego e do ponto de vista
do governo você tem aumento de
arrecadação portanto é um investimento
que faz todo sentido né
sempre que as pessoas me perguntam
mas faz sentido o estado no brasil o
governo investir em cultura
isso aí não deveria ser apenas um
investimento privado não não é
importantíssimo para o país ou por
diversos pontos de vista o investimento
não apenas privado privado sim mas
também o público em cultura o retorno é
muito grande e todos se beneficiam disso
não apenas os artistas os produtores
culturais é o conjunto da população que
se beneficia disso a gente tem um estudo
de caso aqui também da game xp é um
evento que aconteceu pela segunda vez no
rio de janeiro obviamente dedicado à a
games é organizado pelo menos pessoal
que faz a ser xp aqui em são paulo e
também o rock in rio uma parceria das
duas empresas teve um custo de 19
milhões de reais e o impacto econômico
total de 54 milhões de reais com a
geração de 1.332 empregos e cinco
milhões de reais de impostos arrecadados
acho que são dois exemplos aí decidi que
eu chamei de triplo benefício é esse
tributo indo investimento e economia
criativa e não tinha feito aqui uma
pergunta logo no início da minha
apresentação que a pergunta fundamental
quando a ficha vai cair vocês vão me
desculpar por ter usado uma uma metáfora
absolutamente analógica e que talvez não
faça sentido pra muita gente né
há muito tempo que não usamos ficha mais
para absolutamente nada
mas enfim de qualquer maneira a
expressão continua válida quando a ficha
vai cair quando a gente vai se dá conta
aqui no brasil de que nós temos um
tesouro nas nossas mãos que é a
diversidade cultural a criatividade o
talento ea capacidade de transformar
tudo isso em produto e experiência que
os brasileiros têm e algo pelo qual nós
somos admirados no mundo inteiro mas que
muitas vezes nós mesmos não nos damos
conta de que nós temos isso e de que
isso é uma baita de uma alternativa não
apenas de renda
para cada um de nós individualmente mas
na soma de tudo de desenvolvimento para
o nosso país
é impressionante como a gente acha
absolutamente natural que a indústria
automobilística que gera 200 mil
empregos tenha 7.2 bilhões de reais de
incentivos fiscais por ano e muitas
pessoas achem um absurdo que a economia
criativa que gera 1 milhão de empregos
portanto cinco vezes mais tenha um
bilhão e quinhentos milhões de reais de
incentivos fiscais por ano via lei
rouanet
a gente acha um absurdo a gente não
questiona os incentivos para a indústria
automobilística no entanto o setor
cultural e criativo da muito mais ao
país na forma de geração de renda
emprego do que a indústria
automobilística pra ficar apenas num
exemplo então eu espero sinceramente que
a resposta para essa pergunta seja essa
aí assunto as possible porque nós
estamos desperdiçando uma vocação
desperdiçando um potencial que o brasil
tem como eu falei nós podemos ser uma
grande potência cultural e criativo os
meios estão todos aí as condições estão
todas aí é uma questão da gente lembrar
da frase do ao disney de tudo o que ela
significa de tudo o que ela representa e
aplicá la no nosso cotidiano no nosso
dia a dia qualquer um de nós aqui pode
ser o novo audi já e pode construir aqui
no brasil o império como ele fez
a partir do seu camundongo famoso do
mickey é isso aí
muito obrigado pela atenção espero que
eu tenha conseguido passar o recado
valeu